be safe over there boom the propane yeah
it's got a lot going on well jason
isbell in the 400 union are performing
at the virgin hotel this sunday and
earlier in the week i chatted with lead
guitarist sadler vaden who is also
building his own solo career
[Music]
sadler buddy how's it going how you
doing today
hey i'm doing great jc thanks for having
me on
first things first we're looking forward
to the huge show that's coming up this
weekend but i do want to start with this
what was your
very first concert that you went to so
that's a cool question my very first
concert was actually um
the
the band hootie and the blowfish
[Music]
that's a huge concert to start at do you
remember like what songs they played did
they play all the hits that night i mean
they had the you know the album that
most of us know cracked review was out
and was blowing up everywhere and uh
yeah and they actually there's a cool
memory they actually filmed the music
video for their song time
[Music]
how would you describe the sound of the
band if someone's new to your music a
new coming to virgin theater this
weekend how would you describe the sound
of the band
um i would say uh we're probably
more rock and roll than anything and i
know that term doesn't get really used a
whole lot nowadays but
you know i think the term americana gets
used for our music a lot but if folks
don't know what that is you can expect
um
some some loud songs and some quiet
songs and uh i think we sort of ride the
line between folk and rock and roll uh
really well
[Music]
oh you are a big wrestling fan
i am i am a big wrestling fan yes yes
as am i let's go deep here i did you
have a okay
we talked about first concert you
remember the first time you went to a
professional wrestling event and if so
what was that
yeah it was a um i do remember um i
don't know if i remember the year but it
was a wwf
uh in your house um pay-per-view
and
what's uh really funny about my
experience was i had a blast and it was
in florence south carolina um but there
was a storm that rolled through
[Applause]
during
undertaker's uh casket match that was
like 1996 or 1997 because i remember
watching that from my apartment here in
las vegas and the power going out and
trying to figure out how you were
watching it oh yeah i was watching it it
was a big debacle because they had to do
like the matches spree the next night on
monday night raw and do do like a remake
or something it would that's a historic
uh first wrestling event to be at
you can do the most unique interview
either we go from music to wrestling
that's how we do it that's how we do it
you can catch jason isabel in the 400
unit with special guest sean colvin at
the theater inside virgin hotel this
sunday for tickets go to virgin hotels